Після 9 років президентства у Грузії на Міхеіла
Саакашвілі порушили чотири кримінальні справи.
Якщо Саакашвілі депортують із Києва в Тбілісі,
йому загрожує 11 років позбавлення волі.
У деяких справах його заочно визнали винним.
Міхеілу Саакашвілі у Грузії закидають перевищення
повноважень через жорсткий розгін опозиційної
демонстрації у центрі Тбілісі у листопаді 2007-го.
Після тих подій він запровадив надзвичайний стан
на 15 днів - "у зв'язку зі спробою державного заколоту".
Крім того, Саакашвілі звинувачували в розгромі
телекомпанії "Імеді" та її вилученні у засновника,
нині покійного мільярдера Бадрі Патаркацишвілі.
"Імеді" повернули родині власника вже після
зміни влади в Грузії у 2012 році.
Міхеіла Саакашвілі, що прославився боротьбою
з корупцією в Грузії, на батьківщині звинувачують
у розтраті бюджетних грошей.
Зокрема, за даними прокуратури, він витратив
близько трьох  мільйонів євро на кухарів і
масажистів, дорогі готелі та оренду яхт.
Тільки за косметичні процедури для себе і сім’ї
Саакашвілі з 2009 по 2012 рік сплатив близько
370 тисяч євро, стверджує прокуратура.
На майно екс-президента у Грузії у 2014 році
було накладено арешт.
Іще одна гучна справа проти грузинського
екс-президента -  побиття депутата парламенту
Валерія Гелашвілі у 2005 році.
Міхеіл Саакашвілі, за версією прокуратури, вирішив
покарати його за критичний матеріал,
опублікований в одній з грузинських газет.
Екс-президента разом з його близьким соратником
Вано Мерабішвілі звинуватили у нанесенні тяжких
тілесних ушкоджень депутату.
Мерабішвілі, до речі, вже відбуває покарання
в одній із грузинських в'язниць.
На початку цього року Саакашвілі засудили у Тбілісі
до трьох років позбавлення волі через помилування поліцейських,
які відбували покарання за вбивство співробітника
одного з тбіліських банків Сандро Гіргвліані у 2006 році.
За версією слідства, Саакашвілі порадив
правоохоронцям, які викрали банкіра, взяти провину
на себе, і пообіцяв їм натомість швидке звільнення.
Три роки потому грузинський екс-президент
помилував близько 170 колишніх поліцейських
і військових, зокрема, і викрадачів Гіргвліані.